the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence is coming from looking
originally comes from Jodie Foster /
Jill tarter hearing this radio impulses
on a large radio telescope the Very
Large Array it's a wonderful facility
but she hears it using radio signals
after you know we're now celebrating
basically the sixtieth year of the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
with which your dad was deeply involved
and I wonder what would he say about the
state you know we haven't found anything
and you know you're a big believer in
evidence and belief but you know we have
no evidence that they exist positive
evidence at what point you know would he
give up do you think or would you let's
just say firstly at what point do you
turn the telescope's off because we
don't have infinite resources on this
perilous planet you know when do you
give up a search and and just reside
with the feeling that you may never know
well we may never know whether we search
or or we don't but I think that it's
very it's an answer to a deep and
profound question to know if this is if
it's just us or not and you know I think
my dad's curiosity about that was very
profound and - - and again you know this
is one of those things where people
would say what kind of tenants say well
what do you think and he would say I
don't know um and they would say yeah
but like what is your that tell you and
I try not to use my gut for this sort of
thing I try to use my mind and I think
you know it is an important question and
is a profound question and and as long
as we can try to gain a little more
evidence
I think whatever the answer is it would
we it's nothing we could possibly guess
and so it is worth trying to find out
I'm gonna tell us this either way the
answer tells us so much about ourselves